[Music]
hello world and welcome to episode
number 308 of the weekly google cloud
platform podcast i'm carter morgan and
i'm here with my colleague and friend
brian dorsey hey brian
awesome glad to be here i love i love
the hello world intro it's like i don't
know it feels so
core tech concept to me let's keep it
all right i if i'm here and if i
remember i'll try and do it
did oh
did you love anything else about uh
anything that you might have heard
i did hear something different there was
kind of a different vibe to the
the getting going on the podcast this
time
yes we got a brand new jingle it's
exciting it's energetic kind of like
this podcast i hope so uh i'm really
excited about that i'll try to live up
to my end on that uh keep the vibe going
all right well that was one cool thing
this new jingle
i'm sure there's other cool things why
don't we talk about those
[Music]
one the one thing i wanted to say is uh
the call like i want to geek out a
little bit and call attention to the
moment when the 100 trillion digit
resolve final was final and emma opened
it up and looked at it she was the first
human to know what the 100
trillionth digit was and that's just me
i mean i get chills when i think about
it you know we talk about human
exploration in the kind of like the
physical world sense but there's also in
the mathematical sense too so i uh yeah
yeah i gotta give shout out to emma for
that uh particular achievement and emma
i'll let you say it what was the digit
it's zero
the 100 trillion digit of pi is zero
like um this is amazing and and a lot i
mean so
you are pushing the boundaries of kind
of what you could do on computers in
general and in cloud on this really
network chatty problem
um
but i don't think
most people are trying to calculate
digits of pi like what you know for
somebody listening like
why is this um
interesting to know that it's possible
or you know why should people care
i think this is
a very good measure to
sort of show how
how fast the computers have become over
time so we can so there are lots of
benchmarks um
like specific to cpus network storage
and everything
but when you look back and comparing
these numbers um with computers in the
1970s 1980s
and 2020s
then there aren't many that you can
compare across um decades and pi is one
of them like you you you might have
different algorithms we you might have
different architecture software
methodologies but you you can still get
a kind of rough order of magnitude for
the improvements of computers so that's
that's why i really like calculating buy
and there's also in that textbook uh
i'm completely clicking on the name but
it's by uh donald
truth k-u-n-t
they're
yeah uh they they say about like um
calculating pi is one of the ways of
benchmarking uh
um human progress and
um computers i'm highly paraphrasing
here but it isn't it's a nice benchmark
and
uh
one of the professors in in my lab uh
back in the university said uh calculus
pi is a measure to
human progress in civilization so there
are a lot of different takes but i i
really i really think this is
fascinating because you can you can use
the same number same mathematical
constant and compare that over time like
if you look back um
centuries
then you still have the number and you
have you still have the number of
decimals they calculated using like
hands or manual calculators
and today we use electronic computers
also for
computers specifically
this is
a
general um benchmark for everything so
you need to combine everything um cpu
memory storage uh sometimes network if
you decide to use network attached
stretch
and reliability because you need to run
a program for such a long time and
process a lot of data
so
it it checks every everything um every
component every aspect of
the system so i think
um calculating more and more digits
um
makes it
i think um okay let's press it it's a
good proxy to the overall capabilities
of computers so um we we
we didn't calculate 100 trillion digits
in 2019 and today we we do 100
100 trillion digits and somebody
um timothy
mcmillan need to check his pronunciation
but
timothy marcum uh calculated uh 50
trillion digits uh
using
a server in his house
and um another uh university the
university applied science the sciences
in switzerland calculated
62.8 trillion degrees last year and so
each time we see
improvements
and
and compare so when you just look at the
result okay it's a 31 trillion to 100
trillion but if you if you start
breaking it down you have improvements
in cpu we have newer cpus and faster
and we have
faster network faster stretch and the
stretch is actually cheaper than the
last time so we we were able to control
the cost as well so there are a lot of
factors and and i think this is a good
tool to combine everything because as a
developer advocate we
we test our products and write friction
locks right and
this was such a great opportunity to
write a massive friction log and give
feedback to the project teams so that
that's one and
and everyone knows pi
um hey computers became faster now we we
can calculate 100 on this so pi
oh that's cool i
i don't know everything but
we can still do it
so these stories i think these stories
are all important
so sarah when it came to like
visualizing this and understanding these
algorithms even how this data is
represented
on disk now what did you come up with
what did you find
well the first thing that i noticed when
i was looking at historically the
calculations of pi was i wanted to put
together like a historical timeline if
you look in the in the past like you
would get maybe one or two digits of
accuracy every maybe 50 100 years and
i'm really generalizing across
the millennia but but then in the like
since like 1950s
there was this point of inflection when
you have now like a
a pocket calculator and or like some
sort of way to
do like use a computer and uh to to
calculate the digits apply and the graph
just goes it's almost like a a straight
line and then it just starts to like
skyrocket and especially in the past 10
years it's just like extreme exponential
uh growth now especially with uh y
cruncher and i'll defer to elma about
the the the specific algorithms being
used for uh y cruncher but yeah because
of white cruncher now and it's just like
straight um straight like north um in
the graph and the thing that i found
most fascinating is when you look back
at this and is every uh every time there
was a new discovery in mathematics like
differential equations the infinite
series and things like that they would
the
people calculated by the mathematicians
would get more and more accurate
accurate digits of pi they accuracy
improved that's there was these these
new discoveries but what i find
fascinating is now that we have a
hundred trillion digits of pi
what does this imply and i'm just
curious is that are are we going to see
like new mathematics like new math new
interpretations of things now that we
have all these digits could it be known
as an adverse thing that people are
going to discover
like new patterns new trends
whatever it might might be
so yeah like i i i'm visual i like to
see these things and that and then once
i start to see it then i can ask like
these questions so that was part of my
interest as well
that's awesome so kind of you know uh
the outcome maybe generates more
research that would be uh amazing
um
exactly
so actually
i think one of those beginner questions
might be a good lead into this next
thing
um
so you mentioned you know kind of you
know who wrote this algorithm like where
is it run
you know and
so maybe you could answer that and then
emma you know why is this
you know interesting to run in a cloud
so kind of two part i guess you know
what is it where does it run and then
why interesting in the cloud what is
still wrong so we need a big computer um
historically we use supercomputers like
the one you have in university and
research institutes and
until 2009
and since 2009
people said you started using personal
computers like
the one you run games or um applications
you don't usually hear about things from
super computers to personal computers
what's the what's how does that work
right the bottleneck isn't the computer
or like
so the the way you run the calculation
is completely different on these two
different platforms on super computers
you run massively parallel so you use
thousands of cpus and run it very very
quickly and run everything in memory
and on desktop computers you use disks
instead of memory uh disks are slower
but cheaper so you need to run
longer like months
several months
but you can still get the job done and
as long as if you have the same
amount of memory and storage
you
you it it might take longer shorter but
you can still do it
and and the computers the the personal
computers end up winning because it's
you can actually get more discs and
memory even compared to a super computer
is that accurate
there are a lot many people who who can
calculate pi and use super computers for
these purposes and there are like only a
few people working on ipad calculations
before 2009 they stopped doing this
um this is probably one of the biggest
reasons um they probably want to but
there are reasons why this this gets
more difficult on supercomputers
one they are more optimized towards
deep learning machine learning workloads
and more distributed style workloads
instead of this kind of
tightly coupled
this involves a fast fury transform
which is which requires a lot of
communication between those and these
kind of workloads um
running these kind of workloads is
getting increasingly difficult on super
computers because today they have
millions of cpu cores and coordinating
millions of cpu cores in an um enormous
challenge
so
um yes uh i think we we still have
enough memory uh super computers have
petabytes of memory um so we can still
put everything in memory um i think
technically we can use super computers
but they are more expensive
more difficult to use
and on the other hand
storage
ssds hard drives prices went down over
the past decade and i think we are in a
really weird position where you can add
bunch of strategies to personal
computers like uh servers is essentially
personal computers they are the same
architecture you only have single node
and you have stretch supercomputers you
have
thousands sometimes tens of thousands
computers connect to each other so they
are entirely different
but we are in a real position where you
can do this easier somewhat easier with
a personal computer rather than super
computer another thing is we have
a program you can download from the
internet called white cruncher
so you can just go go and
go to the website and download the
program if you have a windows machine or
linux machine you can download it run it
and update billions of trillions digits
by if you have enough memory or
storage so
um
that software appeared around 2009 and
2010
so people started using it and without
this software i think doing this on
cloud
would have been much much more difficult
[Music]
oh that's amazing
what was there anything that just stood
out to you in this episode or anything
that you just really like were charmed
by yeah i mean the whole flow is is
great to kind of like hear it in context
and that sort of thing but i think
you can feel it like we all got really
alive towards the end we're talking
about you know sarah was talking about
like how
you know that
you even kind of you know what other
ways there are to calculate you know all
of us started like apply our usual
tricks to things and that doesn't
necessarily work so i tried a bunch of
stuff and then
this i don't know just kind of more
human discovery aspect of it know that
you know said last digit but you know
maybe somebody had actually done that
but definitely the last 70 digits you
know emma is the first human to have
ever seen those in that that order
together and that's
yeah that's kind of amazing what an
anti-climatic a hundredth trillionth
digit though
zero
zero okay
that's perfect though
yeah it feels right to me
zero wasn't even a number that's a
question we have to ask sarah in the
math background in the future discovery
of xero i think is a whole thing right
and so with that uh it's time to say
goodbye some quick thanks really quick
thank you brian for coming being a great
co-host thank you emma and sarah for
sharing your knowledge thank you kevin
and clarissa for making all this happen
in the background and thank you all at
home for listening we'll see you all
next week
see you next week